Ahora hemos complicado más las cosas.
Tenemos otra vez nuestra masa misteriosa,
en este caso tenemos 3 masas misteriosas que
hemos llamado "x", pero también tenemos esta
vez masas de 1 kilogramo de este lado de la
balanza, la balanza está en equilibrio y
lo primero que me gustaría hacer, es invitarte
a que propongas una expresión algebraica que iguale le escenario que tenemos frente a nosotros,
te voy a dar unos segundos para que lo pienses.
Del lado izquierdo tenemos 3 masas "x" que
suman "3x" y dos masas de 1 kg cada una,
o sea, 2 kg.
Otra forma de pensarlo, es que la masa total
del lado izquierdo, es "3x" más 2, o sea,
3 masas "x" más 2 kg, "3x" más 2.
Ahora observemos que tenemos del lado derecho...
vamos a contar, tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14... 14 masas de
1 kilogramos cada una.
Así que la masa total es 14 kilogramos.
También observamos que la balanza está en
equilibrio, o sea ninguno de los lados sube
ni baja, así la masa total de ambos lados
tiene que ser la misma.
Entonces podemos poner el signo de igual aquí...
ehhh... no, mejor lo voy a poner en blanco,
sí, se ve mejor...
Ehhh... ahora pensemos, ya sea a través de
la expresión algebraica o del dibujo,
¿cómo podemos empezar a trabajar esto?
Por ejemplo, empecemos pensando cómo puedo
quitar estas dos de 1 kg del lado izquierdo
y te voy a dar unos segundos para que lo pienses.
Bueno, pues podríamos simplemente retirar
estas dos masas de 1 kg del lado derecho,
pero debes de recordar que si nada más los
quitamos del lado derecho, entonces este lado
será más ligero y la balanza ya no estará en equilibrio y ya no podríamos utilizar el signo igual.
Lo que tenemos que hacer es quitar dos de
un lado y dos del otro lado y vamos a hacerlo.
Entonces quitamos dos de este lado y dos de
este lado y matemáticamente,
lo que estamos haciendo es restar 2 kg de cada lado.
Del lado izquierdo tengo "3x" más 2,
y le voy a restar 2, entonces solo me queda "3x".
Y del lado derecho tengo 14, al que le resto
2 y eso es igual a 12, solo nos quedará 12.
Y lo puedes observar, cómo quite dos de un
lado y quite dos del otro lado,
de este lado solo quedaron "3x" y nuestra ecuación ahora dice, "3x" es igual a 12
y nuestra balanza sigue en equilibrio.
Lo que te quiero preguntar, otra vez y de
hecho se parece mucho a los ejercicios
que hemos venido haciendo es,
¿qué podríamos hacer para aislar, dejar una sola "x" del lado izquierdo y mantener el equilibrio?
Me gustaría darte unos segundos para que lo pienses.
Pues una idea bastante simple, puede ser multiplicar
el lado derecho por 1/3, o sea si tengo "3x"
y lo multiplico por 1/3 voy a quedar con una
sola "x" pero tendré que también hacerlo
del otro lado, o sea, multiplicar por 1/3
las masas que tengo del lado derecho.
Matemáticamente sería esto, es multiplicar
el lado izquierdo por 1/3, pero si quiero
mantener la balanza en equilibrio, también
tengo que multiplicar por 1/3 el lado derecho.
Y físicamente esto de multiplicar por 1/3,
sería el equivalente a dejar nada más 1/3
de lo que se encuentra en cada lado de la
balanza, entonces en este caso, sería quitar
"2x" del lado izquierdo, para que solo quede
una "x" y del lado derecho,
donde tenemos 12 bloquees de 1 kg, tendríamos que dejar solo 1/3 de 12, que son 4 bloques de 1 kg.
Ahora lo que tenemos será nada más este bloque "x" que está aquí, que estoy indicando
y de este lado, cuatro bloques de 1 kilogramo,
que también estoy indicando.
Y matemáticamente lo que tenemos es que 1/3 que multiplica a 3, que es lo mismo dividir
a 3 entre 3, entonces los 3 se cancelan y me queda "1x" y del otro lado, del lado derecho
tengo 12 que está multiplicado por 1/3, que es lo mismo que dividir 12 entre 3 y eso me queda 4.
Y como todo lo hicimos de ambos lados de la
balanza, la balanza sigue en equilibrio
y entonces podemos decir que la
masa de "x" es igual a 4.